cities it's also repeated that his
government's been surprised by how
fast u.s forces are withdrawing he's
blaming much of the current situation on
the decision to remove the troops
hani says his government has planned to
bring things under control within six
months
but he hasn't gone into detail well the
taliban has taken more territory in
recent weeks than it did at any time
since it fell from power
20 years ago in may it controlled about
20 percent of afghanistan but as u.s and
other foreign troops have been
withdrawing
taliban fighters are ramping up their
attacks in the last two months
half the country has fallen under
taliban rule it's a critical test for
the afghan government as the fighters
advance
and surround the capital kabul in the
past 24 hours the armed group has moved
in from the outskirts
to the hearts of the cities of lashkar
and kandahar
our diplomatic editor james bayes
reports from the capital kabul
as fighting has intensified and moved
into
three of afghanistan's main cities the
president ashraf ghani
has again been addressing his people he
spoke to members of parliament
the third speech gone has made in a week
each time he's talked about the graves
security situation
but there's been no fresh action
announced no
details of his plan to reverse the
taliban advance
we are aware of current problems and
dangers god willing the security and
defense forces will be getting stronger
day by day in the coming six months and
we will reach an optimal situation again
so a sixth month timeline to turn things
around
but with absolutely no detail things are
moving very fast and they're not going
the government's way
and some diplomats are getting impatient
with ghani's approach
they believe he needs to rally his
people around a new
detailed military plan now
as the taliban makes advances their hand
is strengthened in any future
negotiations
it's expected talks in doha will resume
in the next two weeks
the taliban's former finance minister
now living in kabul
says it's time for the president to
accept the group's demands
to release a further seven thousand
troops in exchange for a ceasefire
i must say this to stop all fighting and
to bring and implement the ceasefire
both sides of the conflict
the government and the taliban should
take steps to build trust
it's clear the afghan government needs
not just a plan to turn things around on
the battlefield
but also to change the national mood
there's a perception
even among some government supporters
that the taliban is now winning
james bay's al jazeera kabul
well the u.s and britain are among
countries calling for an immediate
ceasefire across
afghanistan and their embassies are
highlighting allegations
from afghanistan's independent human
rights commission that the taliban
massacred civilians in the town of spin
baldick on the border with pakistan
taliban fighters took control there
on july the 14th posting on twitter the
embassy said
if the accusations are approved they may
amount to war crimes
well in the meantime the united states
says it's going to take in thousands
more afghan refugees who've been working
with the u.s
because of the increased threat from the
taliban the expanded refugee program
will include
afghans linked to u.s funded projects as
well as non-governmental and media
organizations
as the taliban gains more ground the
refugees say they're getting more
worried about their safety
more than 200 afghan interpreters
arrived in the u.s
on friday on rosalind jordan's following
developments
from the u.s state department roz this
sounds in principle like a good offer
from the
the us is it as good as it sounds
well it all comes down to whether the
people who
are theoretically eligible under this
expanded
refugee designation can actually get out
of the country that is the first step
for any person who wants to claim
refugee status
in another country they have to leave
their home country and this is a very
difficult prospect because
many of the people who were working with
u.s based media organizations or ngos
are in parts of the country now
controlled by the taliban
the u.s military is for all intents and
purposes
basically out of the country it has not
been involved
in the relocation so far of afghan
interpreters and their families and so
because they weren't involved in that
process
it's uh basically the same situation
with those who worked
with ngos or media organizations these
people are essentially
on their own they have to find their way
out of the country
in order to start the process of trying
to come to the united states
and the u.s embassy in the uk embassy
demanding a ceasefire from the taliban
is there any indication
that the taliban might be willing to
listen
uh it does seem as if it is they're
making a considerable progress
in reclaiming territory in many parts of
the country
and they're also reestablishing their
political control
in those areas which they have regained
from
afghan national security forces so
unless there is some sort of
breakthrough
in diplomatic talks underway in doha
it's unlikely that the taliban is going
to stop what it's doing
there wasn't even a ceasefire over the
recent eid holiday
rosalind jordan talking to us from the
u.s state department ross thanks very
much indeed
as well as the violence afghans are also
having to deal with floods and
landslides at least a hundred people
have been killed
rescue workers in nuristan province are
digging through debris for survivors
the district's under taliban control
which the government says makes it
difficult
for it to provide assistance food and
shelter
i was sleeping in my house in 10 minutes
the floods came
and destroyed everything 10 members of
my family were killed
we've just found a child and a woman the
others are still missing